قبل شهر او اكثر حطام المسيرات الايرانيه
التي اسقطت في اوكرانيا كشف عن طبيعه
مكوناتها او قطعها انها غربيه بامتياز
اكثر من 200 مكون تقني حددهم المحققون
الاوكرانيون يشكلون الاجزاء الداخليه
للطائره دون طيار الايرانيه الروسيه تم
تصنيع نصف تلك القطع تقريبا بواسطه شركات
مقرها الولايات المتحده وحوالي الثلث
بواسطه شركات في اليابان هذه التقارير
والفحوص دفعت واشنطن لاجراء خطوات متسارعه
لقطع الطريق على المسيارات الايرانيه ومنع
اصولها الى ساحه المعارك في اوكرانيا
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اكدت وجود برنامج
امريكي موسع يهدف للحد من قدره ايران على
انتاج الطائرات المسيره ويشمل البرنامج
حرمان طهران من المكونات الغربيه الصنع
اللازمه لتصنيعها وبالتالي الحقول دون
تسليم السيارات
لتنفيذي هجماتها ضد كيف يشمل البرنامج
الموسع الذي بداته واشنطن تحقيقا حول
الشركات التي صنعت هذه المكونات وفي حال
فشله سيتم تزويد الاوكرانيين بالدفاعات
اللازمه
لاسقاطها وفقه الصحيفه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]